donald trump a fait son choix la juge
conservatrice est une icône hibarette
pour remplacer ruth bader ginsburg
le président américain salue les
qualités de la magistrate
le professeur barrette est une femme à
l'intelligence et au caractère
remarquable elle est éminemment qualifié
pour le poste et je peux vous dire que
je les fais moi aussi j'ai bien regardé
j'ai étudié et vous est éminemment
qualifié pour ce poste vous allez être
fantastique
merci très apprécié des conservateurs en
raison de ses valeurs religieuses
traditionalistes opposés à l'avortement
et nikon hibarette est aux antipodes de
la très progressiste ruth bader ginsburg
sa nomination doit à présent être
validée par le sénat à majorité
républicaine
mais si le sénat a besoin de l'honneur
de me confirmer
je m'engage à assumer les
responsabilités de ce poste au mieux de
mes capacités
j'aime les états unis et j'aime la
constitution des états unis
le camp démocrate lui dénonce cette
décision prise à seulement 38 jours de
la présidentielle
le sénat ne devrait pas se prononcer sur
cette vacance temps que les américains
n'auront pas choisi leur prochain
président et leur prochain congrès la
nomination de la juge fédérale de 48 ans
viendrait temps créer un peu plus la
cour suprême dans le conservatisme
la cour ne compteraient alors plus que
trois juges progressistes sur ces neuf
magistrats